hello there and
happy monday to everyone well everyone
except workstars i don't really like you
guys
today is may 17 2021 i'm dave rubin this
is
the reuben report direct message we've
got a jam-packed
show for you i am in the mood to be
in the studio and as always guys click
that subscribe button and tap that
notification bell you know a whole bunch
of you have been telling me you're not
seeing our interviews lately they're
just not going to your feeds
you know i'm here but by the grace of
the youtube people
but the least you can do is tap that
subscribe thing so that you're actually
subscribed to the channel
and that notification bell so that
supposedly you'll get those
uh notifications in your feed so you can
watch
the reuben report program uh today we've
got three stories for
you and no ads interesting
very interesting uh first off we got a
whole bunch of stuff with the cdc
and the masks and it has just become
very
very clear that the democrats are the
party of anti-science because they want
people to still wear masks even though
the cdc
doesn't want to and i was in dallas over
the last couple days which is why we
didn't do
a show one day last week and or did we
we pre-taped every day
we bring you content every day i did
pre-tapes people i thought maybe on
thursday we didn't
but even when i'm gone we do things it's
just absolutely incredible
but i was in dallas and dallas is in a
state called texas
and texas is a wonderful place it is
republican run it is a red
state and there were people wandering
around not wearing masks it was almost
to the point where if you saw someone in
a mask
it was a signal that they were actually
insane
especially if they were outdoors it's
like oh you're a crazy person
i feel bad for you then
i came back to la and yesterday morning
i posted a picture of this
in the reuben report community uh i went
to i had to get some cream cheese in the
morning
wanted some cream cheese on my bagel and
we didn't have any so i said i will go
to the supermarket i hate going to the
supermarket because i hate being
out around these blue and on weirdos so
i basically don't leave my house but
it's good to every now and again get
every few weeks get in the car make sure
you still know how to drive you know
so i drove over there and i was going to
walk in without a mask because the cdc
is saying we don't have to wear masks
anymore and it's also ridiculous and all
that stuff
and then of course someone asked me to
put a mask on when i got in there i saw
another woman try to walk in
without a mask and she was like but the
cdc guidelines say we don't have to wear
masks and the woman was like oh maybe
we'll do it next week like it was just
like
pure drivel nonsense but i put i took a
picture with the cream cheese so if you
want to see what it's like for me on a
sunday
when i'm wearing the baseball cap and
i'm wearing a mask and i'm not happy
join us at reubenreport.locals.com
anyway
red states are doing it right blue
states are ridiculous
what am i doing here so we are going to
talk all about cdc stuff and just the
ridiculous messaging coming out of our
administration
uh the second story we're going to cover
a little bit about what's going on
in the middle east and by the way i want
to thank you you know i have a feeling
about the
the comments which is that i try not to
dive into the youtube comments
uh generally speaking i do all my
interaction with you guys on locals as
you know
um but because i feel like i did a
pretty deep dive of everything happening
in the middle east on i believe that was
wednesday that we did that
uh no that was wednesday we did the q a
you know it was wednesday
um and i did about a half hour and most
of it was off the top of my head and
talking about the history and what's
going on and just some of the
philosophical issues behind everything
and the reality on the ground and all
that
and we just got so many nice comments
and a lot of people saying oh i didn't
know this but i googled it and you are
actually right on this or
it was just it was just nice to see so i
thank you guys for that so we're gonna
uh go into this interview that benjamin
netanyahu the prime minister of israel
did on face the nation
yesterday some really interesting stuff
and then third the
us army under our dear leader joe biden
that 78 year old man with dementia has
now decided that climate change is one
of the main things that we're going to
wage war on because you can blow it out
of the sky apparently
so it's it's gonna be a jam-packed show
as i said i am in a good mood and ready
to roll so here we go
so first i want to start with video this
is yesterday on abc
cdc director rochelle walensky
was defending new mass guidance for
vaccinated americans now oddly just a
few days ago
she was saying we should all still be
wearing masks and we should be social
distancing
then the cdc said no you don't have to
do that stuff and
i believe it's martha raddatz at a uh
abc
actually did a nice job questioning here
take a look
it was just tuesday when you sat before
a senate committee
and you were adamant then that masking
and social distancing should remain in
place
but the washington post is reporting you
had already approved a decision to
change the guidance
when it was finally announced on
thursday it came as a huge surprise and
left some
administration officials doctors
businesses off guard
so why so suddenly and why did you not
tell the senate panel
what you had decided
thank you good morning marcia thanks
martha thanks for having me i
am you know the guy first of all let's
celebrate this moment
um we're at a place in this pandemic
cases have been coming down
more than a third just in the last two
weeks we have vaccine now
across this country widely available for
anyone who wants it
and we now have science that has really
just evolved even in the last two weeks
that demonstrates that these vaccines
are safe they are effective they are
working in the population just as they
did in the clinical trials
all right so richelle wilinski the
director of the cdc is a silly
unserious person first off i'm not a
scientist but i do know something
science doesn't evolve you can find out
new things but science does not
evolve what can evolve are policies as
you get new information as it relates to
science and fact okay
so nothing evolved in the science in the
last two weeks right there's no suddenly
new information about this or that or
the other thing
but the administration has been trying
deliberately
to scare people by the way joe biden
even
accidentally when every few weeks he
says something that's true
he accidentally said that a couple weeks
ago remember when they asked him they
said well wait a minute it was one of
the press
things where he comes back to the podium
and he's not supposed to be there and
he's always like oh i shouldn't do this
i'm going to be in a lot of trouble and
it's like well who are you going to be
in trouble with joe
but basically they said to him well why
joe are you wearing the mask when we're
outdoors you're not standing here
everybody you've been vaccinated it's
against the science
and he's like well we just want people
to keep wearing the masks and it's kind
of messaging and you know but
it's like they're telling us that
they're lying to us this woman rachelle
willenski you may remember another clip
that we played a couple weeks ago
where she sort of she was being
interviewed by somebody and she was like
i'm just gonna go off script for a
moment
and just tell you and she basically was
like winter is coming
everything's gonna be horrible do you
remember that find the clip if you
haven't seen it i mean it's just
extraordinary and what she was talking
about was that these places
like florida and texas are reopening and
oh my god something really really
horrible is going to happen and i'm here
from the cdc and i have to scare you
guys
otherwise my grift is up well her grift
is almost
up because people have just had it and
actually when i talked
to people in dallas which is a free city
in the free state
of texas everybody that i talk to you
know people usually come up to me but i
would actually
i went to a bar get this i actually i
was meeting a friend and i sat
at a bar you can't do that here in la we
don't let people sit at bars
so i sat tomorrow night a few minutes
and i started chatting with a couple
people
and everyone thinks this is all [ __ ]
like you people have lied to everybody
to the point
that you've you've shot your load and
you've got nothing left there that
nobody listens to you anymore because of
what you have done in your mixed
messaging
and all that nonsense so all that being
said i want to give a shout out to abc's
martha raddatz
you asked a good question that seemed
like some level of journalism and
i believe credit is due and i want to
give it to you so that was a small
golf clap for you martha rad it's good
work there all right let's go
we got some more video because it
doesn't end with the ridiculousness from
this administration this is video from
blaze tv
jen pasaki being confronted over cdc
mask rules
does the president still think that
these red state governors who were a
little bit ahead of the federal
government in
lifting the mass mandates had
neanderthal thinking
well again i would say that even with
this guidance that's out there the
guidance is not
telling states and localities exactly
how they should implement
as you know there are some localities
and govern states in the country
that have higher rates of vaccination
than others some communities that have
higher rates of vaccinations than others
and we even know as this is being
implemented that different localities
businesses will implement it in the way
that they feel will help
ensure their community is safe but i
know i am reassured by
listening to the health the guidance of
health and medical experts
uh not political decision making so
that's the point we're at now
and my last one annie slavitt said this
morning that the white house found out
the
mass guidance was going to change at 9
00 p.m the night before
were you guys surprised that in the nine
o'clock hour at 9
25 the cdc director was on cnn saying
that the
science wasn't there yet uh i didn't
watch that interview i can just tell you
that a
small number of uh that they were and we
were informed
the night before uh that the guidance
that they made a decision about the
guidance they plan to announce it the
next day
could you imagine anyone being more
inauthentic or inauthentic than jen
pasaki i mean she really
just it would be impossible if you said
her jen pasaki what's your favorite
color
i think she would say four like the
woman is completely incapable
of saying an honest direct statement she
didn't answer the question there at all
the question by the fox reporter
was quite good it was basically hey now
that you're seeing what's going on here
and cdc rules changing everything
does biden regret saying that those
republican governors have neanderthal
thinking
by opening up and then she just babbles
on for a while and she's sort of like
well we have to just follow the science
followers lines and not make political
decisions
except that's completely the reverse of
what has been proven
to be true what has been proven to be
true is that the people
like rochelle that we just watched from
the cdc they just want more and more
endless control while fauchi were in the
sixth inning well the sixth inning this
game wrapped up
pretty quick i guess the last three
innings were all consecutive strikeouts
because everyone's over it buddy
but what she's saying there is well no
we have to listen to the science and the
science constantly changes which is what
led us from two weeks to flatten the
curve to a year and a half later
where we're walking around with half the
country having mental problems related
to
wearing masks and everything else we
actually
got answers and are now actually
starting to open up because of political
decisions
so she completely says the wrong thing
thank god i really mean this
thank god for ron desantis in florida
thank god for greg abbott in texas thank
god for a couple of the other governors
in red states
who said no we're not doing this [ __ ]
anymore enough of you ridiculous people
it is not our job as government
officials to tell everyone how to live
every second of the day we can't keep
everybody safe every second of the day
and we got to give it to you guys a
little bit of belief
in your ability to live as a human being
and a little bit of chance
we're not some sort of airtight system
that can tell everyone what to do all
the time
that's what america is all about that's
what freedom's all about that's what
limited government's all about it's
exactly what the constitution
laid out in federalism and all of these
things you guys know all this so
it was political decisions by brave
political people shout out particularly
to those two guys
greg abbott and ron desantis that
actually
forced the issue imagine what the
situation would be right now
had they not done that and we didn't
have any evidence
that actually by opening up you can keep
the numbers plummeting well we would
still be in this ridiculous situation
being led by fools like rochelle
from the cdc and then being lied to by
ridiculous buffoons
like jen pasaki but if you think those
two are the only ones
that are ridiculous oh i've got one for
you
this is from msnbc mayor laurie
lightfoot of chicago who is vaccinated
she wants vaccinated people to keep
wearing masks
this is good news you say you will
follow the cdc's guidance
what does that mean should people in
chicago wear masks or not
um i know for me personally i'm going to
continue to wear a mask in public
and encourage others to do so um we've
got to make sure
that people are continuing to follow the
public health guidance that has gotten
us this far
and mask i think are a big and important
part of that to say
well if you're if you're vaccinated you
don't have to wear a mask that's great
but what about all the other people that
are out there that aren't vaccinated
and there's no way to know that so i
think for the time being
most people are going to continue to
wear masks
outside and outside of their homes and i
think that's smart
the virus is still here the virus is
still real we're still seeing deaths
every day
so we can't afford to feel like
the virus is gone and suddenly we can
just go back to 2019.
that's just not going to happen okay
lori lightfoot is a ridiculous person
you know there's a meme out there that a
lot of people online say that she looks
like beetlejuice i don't really want to
comment on that but if you're if you're
specifically thinking that
uh you know beetlejuice as far as i
remember the movie i haven't seen it for
about 20 years he did come back from the
dead and he was able to do all these
incredible tricks so maybe she has some
ability to do some stuff we don't know
about
but there's a couple things there now
first off she's absolutely coming out
against science if we are to believe
that the cdc is doing their stuff based
on
evolving science as rochelle just told
us well then
lori lightfoot a democratic uh mayor in
chicago
is against science just as jen pasaki's
against science and old joe is against
science these people
are against science by their definition
of what science is not by mine okay
so that's number one number two that
hypocrite right there that you just saw
she wasn't wearing masks during the
riots remember when there were riots all
over the country for like a year
and she was out there with black lives
matter people and she was in a big crowd
we played the video
and she wasn't wearing a mask so i see
lori let me get this straight
at the peak of the pandemic when it fit
your political narrative you could be
out on the street without a mask and i
think she said something to the effect
because she got caught a few times doing
it
one of the times was after biden
officially got elected remember that
happened on a saturday after
five days of what the hell is going on
here and she was out on the streets and
she was like
well we basically we have to be able to
celebrate and smile sometimes right
and it's like okay this is all
just drivel nonsense um so she
didn't wear a mask during the riots now
the cd says you don't have to wear a
mask but she wants to keep people afraid
because democrats are using fear and
anti-science
basically as their party platform there
is no policy that makes sense i would
if there is a democrat watching this and
i know some democrats do please tell me
a policy
that makes any sense related to any of
this
that is being brought forth by your dear
leaders now you could say well dave what
about the republicans and it's like well
actually i can give you a lot of
policies that the republicans
are doing that makes sense which is
basically opening the states
letting people make decisions on their
own et cetera et cetera by the way
if you're still on the fence about lori
right foot you know
uh how many people died in chicago this
weekend you want some info that's not
going to be on cnn guarantee you're not
going to hear this on cnn and maybe
brian stelter or you media matters
losers that are watching this maybe you
can get this to the people over at cnn
41 people were shot this weekend
in cnn uh in cnn 41 people were shot
this weekend
in chicago okay now you're not going to
hear that on cnn they're not going to
write it about it in the new york times
because it does not fit the blue and on
narrative that there are
roving gangs of white supremacists and
police police officers
mauling down black people because
basically all of those shootings it's
black on black violence now we can talk
about all the reasons for all of that
but the point is this is a ridiculous
woman who is doing nothing
as her city crumbles and people kill
each other and she doesn't care i mean
the truth is she doesn't care and the
mainstream media doesn't care what they
care about is keeping you masked and
keeping you afraid and allowing violence
that they think is okay
if it doesn't fit the narrative that
america is a uh
white supremacist state one more thing
on this which is that california
is officially reopening apparently on
june 15th which is you know a little
over
three weeks from now that's a completely
arbitrary date set by gavin newsom
well arbitrary not really because it's
an arbitrary date in that it has nothing
to do with science
but he delayed for a while so that
suddenly in june as the recall is
happening he can start getting some good
news
he's been tweeting all about these tax
rebates people are going to get
which i love when progressives say that
tax rebates we're going to help you with
tax rebates how about you just don't
take the money from us in the first
place how about you lower
the taxes you evil cartoon character
would you do that maybe
instead of re we give you the money it's
not your money gavin newsom ugh these
people like they're just
absolutely awful anyway starting you
know what i'm gonna make a commitment
starting today everything that i do in
la and again i don't go out that often
but everything that i do
any store that i enter i'm not gonna
wear a mask and if i'm told to wear a
mask
then if i need to get in there i guess i
will like i'm not here to start a riot
and fight with people but i'm going to
at least try it again
and see what happens oh and i want to
give a shout out to trader joe's
because trader joe's as a company
announced
that they will no longer have mask
mandates in their store and actually
someone in the reuben report community
tweeted a picture
posted a picture that they sent to me
that they went
to a trader joe's in socal i don't know
if it was in
los angeles proper but in socal and they
did not wear a mask uh oh wait michael
what are you telling me here
you didn't wear a mask wow all right so
michael is telling me right now
my radical right wing freedom extremist
producer michael
went to trader joe's in los
angeles and did not wear a mask and he
thanked the manager you are a good man
mike i'm going to you want to go to
trader joe's later let's go
let's i'm not kidding that's it guys
we're going to trader joe's for lunch
we're going to go to the local trader
joe's and see what happened we're going
to take some pictures we're going to
trader joe's
all right let's move on uh okay
obviously big
big mess in the middle east and if you
want to see how just social media just
makes
absolutely everything worse i mean
anytime anything happens
related to israel the amount of
misinformation and disinformation
and hysterical partisan lunacy and just
some of the awful stuff from
from the squad and just absolutely
ridiculous stuff i mean aoc
basically saying that israel is an
apartheid state
israel has 20 arab population that votes
they have more voting rights than in any
arab
nation in the middle east that is simply
a fact and they don't want to leave they
always do poll after poll but you guys
like to leave
would you like to go to another state
and they don't want to because they're
free there doesn't mean everything's
perfect there's no such thing as perfect
but israel has done more for a
multicultural society in a really rough
part of the world and just the abject
lies and then there's a couple videos
that i didn't even want to show them on
the show today because they're so
depressing but
but literally jewish people being hunted
down on the street
by a mob of palestinian activists that
happened in canada
there was some stuff in florida there
was some stuff
where else in london where there were
there was a caravan
with palestinian flags screaming you
know hunt down the jewish women i mean
just like horrific stuff
horrific stuff and jews have been
through this before there's about a 5
000 year history of
you know bad things happening and yet
we're still here well anyway uh benjamin
netanyahu who is the prime minister of
israel
went on face the nation and faced what i
thought were extremely difficult
somewhat slanted questions but difficult
questions are just fine and i thought
the moral clarity that he talked
with uh was quite impressive so we're
going to play you about a minute and a
half of it and just take a listen
and then we will analyze prime minister
the arguments about how careful israel
have been are familiar ones to your
critics
and in this case with 181 palestinians
dead 52 of them children there's
significant criticism amnesty
international has asked the criminal
international criminal court to look
into a refugee camp attack
the u.n is meeting today foreign
ministers of the eu are meeting
and and the the response has been like
this one from the foreign minister
of ireland israel has international
legal obligation to protect children in
conflict
and are not doing so that's just a false
i mean the reason we have these
casualties is because hamas
is criminally attacking us from uh
civilian neighborhoods from schools from
homes from office buildings
that's what they're doing but uh and
we're taking action trying to
target them with as great precision as
we can unfortunately there are
occasionally civilian casualties which
we regret but here's what happens
when the international community attacks
israel
they're actually encouraging hamas to
continue these attacks
because hamas says it's great we're both
killing israeli civilians
and uh unfortunately some of ours and
they're happy with their own civilian
casualties because it gets that
uh the international community to focus
their attacks on israel and
hamas that's wrong it's both wrong and
unproductive and i can tell you that
there have been many studies by serious
military analysts
who have compared israel's actions with
that of other western armies
in similar situations fighting a radical
islamist
whether it's in iraq or in afghanistan
or
elsewhere and you know how prolonged
those conflicts are how many
casualties are caused so i think there
is a
there has to be a measure of fairness
there has to be a measure of
reasonableness
in projecting this kind of criticism
against the israeli army that is second
to none
in seeking to minimize civilian
casualties while protecting our own
civilians
you know if hamas would simply move
these rockets out of the civilian areas
if they moved their command posts out of
these homes and offices
uh then there wouldn't be any problem
let me ask you mr prime minister
but the fact is they're sending
thousands of rockets on our cities
with a specific purpose of murdering our
civilians
from these places let me ask you guys
what would you do let me ask what
happened to washington and to new york
you know
you know what you do let me ask you at
the very
question what would you do if it was
happening in washington and new york you
know damn well what you do we'll get to
that just a sec but there was a whole
bunch of stuff there so first off
uh the question is related to what the
foreign minister of ireland said
and this is how silly most of politics
has become
like we there is a conflict happening in
the middle east
and the foreign minister of ireland
which is thousands and thousands of
miles away this is not a shot at ireland
specifically but the foreign minister
says oh you have to fight your war this
way
as thousands of rockets are being shot
indiscriminately to kill as many of your
people as possible and thankfully
they're not killing that many people
because of the iron dome they're
designed to just blast and hit
absolutely everywhere
and then there's this miracle the iron
dome which is actually a modern miracle
right out of star wars
that they can shoot rockets out of the
sky uh the implication
is that if only more of your people were
dying if this was only a little more
proportionate so if we could see 20 dead
palestinians next to
you know 18 israelis maybe 18 dead
israelis
maybe the proportion would be right the
left loves this thing that somehow your
everything is supposed to be
proportional everyone knows this makes
absolutely
no sense if someone was attacking you
with a knife would you be like
whoa whoa hey slow down now uh can i see
the size of that knife let me get in the
kitchen see if i have something
comparable of course you wouldn't
there is a doctrine in military terms
called deterrence and what you want to
do is you want to hit people
so that they won't hit you again there
are videos of israelis calling people
saying get out of the buildings
i mean they blew up a building where ap
was associated press that we know
everybody knows that hamas was operating
in the building why was the ap
in a building with hamas i mean i think
you could probably figure out why
um and i also and then the media was
going crazy oh my god israel
attacked the ap building but all year
long we've been told that
attacking property isn't a problem
nobody died attacking property is not a
problem right a property is not violence
words are violence but blowing up
buildings isn't violence i mean these
everything that the left has been
throwing at us for the last year is
being so exposed
in this nonsense but the point on the
ireland thing is like why should he care
why should he care imagine if there were
rockets being fired from the uk
into ireland do you think the irish
people would be like well what does the
israeli foreign minister think
every nation exists to defend their
people
that is just a fact uh the next point
is that the iron dome you know the iron
dome is saving lives on both sides it's
not just that the iron dome is saving
lives on the israeli side but imagine if
they didn't have the iron dome and
thousands of rockets
were just landing in their territory and
blowing up cities and killing people
they would have to attack much more
intensely than they're doing
thus they are saving lives on the
israeli side and
on the palestinian side that's too um
[Music]
and also there's a more broad point here
that i wanted to bring up which is
what country wouldn't defend their
citizens in essence what they're saying
to israel basically is
you know somehow you're wrong here
you're just wrong even though there's
literally not one
jew in gaza there never was a country
called palestine as we talked about last
week
palestine gaza before 1967 was part of
egypt
it still has a border with egypt but
they don't let any of the palestinians
out
they're our brothers and sisters why
isn't anyone in the media saying hey
guys why don't we just let there's only
you know a couple million of you guys i
think about two million of you
if it's so bad there and yes your
population keeps spiking as aoc is
calling it a genocide but why don't you
guys just
move over to egypt i mean there's the
whole sinai peninsula there it's it's
pretty huge i've actually been there i
hiked
to mount sinai over there um and
but they don't say that right because
people don't really want a resolution to
this
um also netanyahu started saying it but
then he switched in the middle of the
sentence
but hamas is killing their own people
too not only by launching the rockets
from
civilian places but their own rockets
are landing in gaza
and killing their own people nobody
cares about that there was also a father
and daughter an israeli arab father and
daughter
that were killed they are israeli they
live in israel they were killed by hamas
rocket nobody cares about them
either and then to the other point that
i just made what would you do
i mean i guess that's what we all have
to think about all of these things let's
say you were being attacked
whether you think about your family your
home your community whatever it is what
would you
do if you had the means to defend
yourself
you would defend yourself it's as simple
as that and by the way you can do that
from the
hamas perspective as well if they think
that this is freeing them
from oppression somehow then i guess
they should keep firing rockets but
everyone knows that's not what it's
doing right it's just
making things worse but the the moral
equivalency here
is just absolutely ridiculous on top of
the the ace
the just a historical take that these
buffoons
in the you know the squad and the rest
of these people have is just awful and
social media
is making this much worse much much
worse because it is amplifying lots of
terrible things
there was a writer who's a cnn
contributor who wrote
something to the effect over the weekend
uh that hitler was right
cnn contributor he has written articles
on cnn.com
and apparently that cnn has that was
even a bridge too far for cnn apparently
they've gotten rid of him but he's a
blue check
twitter guy the head of hamas you know
calling to wipe out all the jews
he's still on twitter scary donald trump
is not so we just lit we live in a time
that is an assault on reality is an
assault on history
and it is an absolute assault
on truth and i'm being told right now an
illinois congresswoman
says that hitler was right on one thing
jesus christ who
do we have her name do we have the name
of that person we'll see if we can find
the name of that person but anyway i
know this is
this is a complex topic and i will keep
talking about it
and and hopefully we can just sort of
break some of the lies here
um but listening to the the progressive
caucus
in the senate with the absolutely insane
things that they were saying
there's only one place in the middle
east that is anything remotely close
to coexistence how's it going for racial
minorities in syria
or iraq or iran or there i think there
was literally one jew left
in egypt and asked the coptic christians
how's it going in egypt
there's one country that although they
didn't do it perfectly they kind of did
it right and they're obscenely tiny
and they're told to just lay over and
die and frankly i would rather
stand up and be hated than lay down and
be loved so that that's what i would
uh prefer all right we're gonna shift
for a second i'll see if we can get that
person's name by the end
um but the u.s army if you want to talk
about sort of what what a serious army
has to do
in a in a horrific circumstance that's
the story that we just covered
versus what what a sort of silly army
would be doing well the u.s army is now
treating climate change
as a serious threat to the u.s we
we just know that it's just not true
that doesn't make me a climate denier
but obviously this ever
encroaching oh you must do all of the
woke things it has now infected
the u.s army so the headline there u.s
army addressing
climate change threats that's what
they're going to be doing
and here's a quote from the u.s army
press release it's
it's a lot people here we go climate
change is a serious threat to u.s
national security interests and defense
objectives
the effects of climate change can cause
humanitarian disasters undermine weak
governments
and contribute to long-term social and
economic disruptions
warming temperatures open new theaters
of operations for military and
commercial use
while extreme weather events and rising
sea levels threaten infrastructure and
economic output
trigger large scale population
displacement migration
and exacerbate food and water insecurity
in line with the president and the
secretary of defense's direction the
army is prior
prioritizing climate change
considerations in its threat
picture strategic plans operations
and installations look i am not sitting
here telling you that
none of that is true at all that some
level of climate change at some level
could have something to do with
something
but we are living in such a time where
as i i mean it's just like
i should just have a rubber mallet i
think i have a rubber mallet in the
garage
we're going to keep that on set for now
on and every now and again i'm just
going to whack my head with a rubber
mallet
because of the repetition of some of
this stuff does this seem does this
story of what i just read to you does it
seem like this is what really the u.s
military and the army should be planning
for we've got massive problems
with china right and there's more and
more evidence now leaking out that the
kovid might have come from a wuhan lab
we're gonna have to deal with that
if it turns out to be true i thought
russia had installed the president of
the united states now if they did
then we'd be technically at war with
russia which also you knew
the entire time with the russia thing
that it was [ __ ] from the beginning
because otherwise
everyone in congress that thought trump
was hitler you've been
you've installed hitler as president of
the united states russia
every one of them would have been
pushing for a declaration of war against
against russia but oddly nobody did and
then we had two ridiculous
sham impeachments we're not a serious
country right now we're really not a
serious country we are we are governed
i mean first off the guy at the top the
figurehead at the top and i say
figurehead because he's obviously not
really the president you know he's
technically
the president of the united states but
but really not the president of the
united states he has dementia that's a
problem
we have now a series of governors that
refuse to follow the science i will give
murderer andrew cuomo a little credit
though because i just heard right before
we started it sounds like new york
is about to open up so at least he's
following the cdc guidelines now while
gavin newsom won't
but then we have the cdc and all these
ridiculous the who all of these
organizations
who are all sort of in bed together i
can't piece together what that whole
thing is
but you have giant government globalist
organizations
that sort of love the fact that the
united states is just drowning itself
and thank god i'll say it again thank
god
for a couple brave governors that are
leading the charge back on this and
thank god for new technologies
and the and thank god for crypto and all
of the people
that are fighting to save this thing
because if you think that the democrats
are going to save this thing and by the
way if you think
it's not that the republicans won't
because the republicans are far better
uh but but
the answer again is not uh is not a
governmental
answer okay just to back up finally
before i say goodbye
uh freshman u.s senator representative
mary miller
of illinois hitler was right on one
thing
he said whoever has the youth has the
future
well that well first off why would you
need hitler to come up with your
comment on that and it turns out that
the comment is often attributed
to hitler who organized youth groups to
introduce children
to nazi ideologies that's obviously
where
the hitler youth came from ronald lauder
who's from the world jewish congress
he's the president over there he said
one might expect this from white
supremacists
or neo-nazis but hearing the words
hitler was right from the mouth
of a member of the united states
congress is beyond acceptable behavior
by any standards look
the progressives are being exposed as
what they are they love
intersectionality they love the
they love the oppressed or the perceived
oppressed they don't like minorities
that succeed and in many ways
israel is the ultimate example of that a
people with a horrifically brutal
history
for any of you that you don't have to be
jewish to understand this if you know
anything about if
anything about the old testament
anything about any jewish holiday it's
like a lot of jews always killed
and then thank god we all weren't killed
now let's eat well the jews have
survived and the left hates that that
really is the truth that's what aoc
and ilhan omar and rashida to leave hate
that this that this obscenely tiny
country
has actually figured out a way to
survive and thrive in a in a time of
absolute chaos
and you know i think uh i think the
israelis have been through far worse
than than
our ridiculous congresswoman uh anywho
uh i enjoyed the show today i felt
felt like i said what i needed to say i
hope you enjoyed it i hope you're having
a nice day oh i want to say one other
thing actually
which is i was on elijah schaefer's
podcast when i was in
dallas i did a bunch of shows with with
the blaze guys and i just loved the
blaze and i
i went to to glenn beck's house and i
drove in his
fancy car and we just had a great time
but i was on elijah shafer's podcast
which you can find at
blazetv.com and he was talking
about the clown pill and what the clown
pill is so you guys know about the blue
pill
most people have taken the blue pill
they don't know what truth is they don't
want to know what the truth is they just
if something is said in the new york
times
if something is said on siena and that's
somehow true right that's good enough
for them
ignorance is bliss go on living your
life right just be
like a cog in the machine and that's
what the system wants you to be
a cog in the machine then there's the
red pill and of course you guys know
what the red pill is the red pill is
oh you're going to start seeing reality
you're going to start seeing the
[ __ ] you're going to see the way big
tech manipulates us you're going to see
the way
mainstream media lies to us but it's
tough right like it was tough for neo in
the matrix to accept all that stuff
and when you accept reality as it is and
that the world is how it is not as you
wish it to be
well then that's tough that's tough and
then what happens i've mentioned this a
few times is
the scary part of the red pill is you
could get black pill and black pill is
when you're like oh
man the system is freaking evil the
system
is absolutely evil and then you're just
like i'm gonna check out i'm just
depressed there's nothing i can do
and i don't want you guys to be black
pill that that if i have one job
with this show it's to not let you guys
be black pill because we must fight and
we must do it together but then elijah
introduced me to a new pill
which is what happens after the black
pill although i'm hoping maybe you can
just skip the black pill altogether
which is the clown pill and the clown
pill is when you're like you know what
this is all just [ __ ] and all i'm
gonna do is make fun of it pasaki's a
[ __ ]
rochelle from the cdc's an idiot the
president has dementia and i'm gonna
make fun of all of it and i'm gonna keep
a smile on my face and i'm gonna
remain happy and find people that are
interesting and good and all that stuff
so i kind of like the clown pill
it might be a little too over the top
for me i have to do a little more
research on the clown pill
uh and i know we're going to find out
now that the clown pill is being issued
by white supremacists and yadda yadda
but that's the route that i like right
like let's keep doing this stuff with a
smile on our face with a little bit of
humor
and i think everything will be okay now
guys uh part one of my interview if you
have not
the clip's already blowing up we put it
up this morning but if you haven't seen
it part one of my
newest interview we did it in studio
here with michael mallis is on youtube
right now
the full episode is already up ad free
five days early at
rubinreport.locals.com
and malice just just trust me on this
one watch the video just click
over there and watch the video malice
dresses up
let's just say he is he is in character
for this interview but putting aside
his incredible outfit uh he is just one
of the great political thinkers that
we've got i just
absolutely love the guy i absolutely
love him so again the full episode at
reubenreport.locals.com
okay i've got a busy day i'll be
announcing my book title finally
hopefully
in the next two weeks two weeks
two weeks-ish uh i think you're going to
dig it i'm really psyched
and then we'll tell you more about the
rollout on that thing and what my goal
will be with the new book i'll say this
right now
is i want you know i made the new york
times best sellers list last time
despite they really didn't want to put
me on there
and we know that we sold way more copies
than the number that they put me on the
list
and all that stuff but i want to sell so
many copies of this freaking book that
they are
forced to put us at number one like i
want to blow it out of the water
so that this craptastic former place of
journalism known as the new york times
that we can completely expose them
because the numbers are real sales
numbers are real
so either they put us on number one and
it's like they have to eat crow as the
new york times
or they don't put me at number one but
then i fully expose them for doing it
because i'm having fun
because the clown pill i snorted it this
morning all right guys
have a great day enjoy yourselves get
out there take a walk
have a glass of water i have a little
glass of water with some lemonade in the
morning
that usually gets me going that's all
that's it see you later okay
bye
you